good morning John good morning Hank
actually that was - Oh energy let's have
them do it John I want to let you know
that it is possible to clean your lens
oh no that's not something that I do
that's just not part of my aesthetic but
go on we are currently on the main stage
of VidCon 2015 lot of people kind of
surprises me that we've only been doing
this for for eight years yeah I mean
eight years is a lot of time by some
measures right obviously it's most of
YouTube's 10 year history but it's also
a very short amount of time like it's
only two presidential terms a baby in
eight years only becomes an 8 year old
and an 8 year old is basically just like
a big baby
mmm strong mate strong disagree I would
say that an 8 year old is never just a
smaller adults either the 8 year olds
here blathers hey there are people at
VidCon who are younger than the first
vlogbrothers video and now I have become
aware of how old I am so there have been
many important cultural institutions
that have come out of online video in
the last eight years Justin Bieber the
double rainbow guy and of course at the
ice bucket challenge we dream about Bill
Gates I don't know if Bill Gates is here
tonight bill he's probably in Tanzania
doing something about poverty we love
you bill we wish you were here but what
would you have other work it's important
Jenna yeah can I just interrupt you to
say that your glasses are so dirty that
you have no right to make fun of my way
so we started big gun in 2010 in the
basement of a hotel in Los Angeles and
Century City it is somewhat bigger than
that now but we had a lot of people then
and here are some of them this is the
first VidCon
Tyler Oakley rhettandlink Dave de chelly
Karl is there I just seen is there many
of these people are still at VidCon this
year and for many of them their lives of
change dramatically Smosh has gone on to
like make movies got the movie came up
this week and kids movie came out this
week and you know that is true yes go
see Paper Towns I did credibly anxious
I've been feeling a little bit like
maybe maybe maybe they shouldn't have
scheduled the minigun and the movie on
the same day
maybe I should retake that so when we
started VidCon in 2010 we knew that
YouTube was a big deal but we had no
idea like how big of a deal it was going
to become right like we did not know
that we were taking power away from
giant corporations that that made
content and they didn't either yeah but
they've realized it now and they're here
and they're being very nice time yeah so
thank you giant corporations for your
presence making all everything so fans
stay in YouTube but be cool about it
that's all we ask
I'm very I'm proud of it
[Music]
right guys we're trying to walk here I'm
very proud of VidCon but I'm mostly
proud to be some small part of this
giant weird cultural explosion that has
taken the power and put it into the
hands of the people that it should be in
which is the people who watch the
content and the people who make it and
that's that's the spirit of it come from
for me for those of you inside of the
camera thank you for paying attention
and for being parts of these communities
thank you and don't forget to be awesome
and hey I will see you on Tuesday that's
my video so John I will see you on
Friday
now you say that that's your life yeah
John very well said and I'll see you on
Friday really good work there